we will reconstruct Ukraine but when we
are reconstructing Ukraine let's do it
in the right way let's do it in the
spirit of the new European Bauhaus
the new European Bauhaus is the soul of
our climate agenda the European green
deal it promotes a sustainable inclusive
and beautiful future in the European
Union and Beyond its borders in Ukraine
[Music]
shown remarkable resilience and unity
rebuilding the country also means
rebuilding local communities ensuring an
inclusive process that preserves this
incredible social Collision
[Music]
we start with free first modules but we
hope that more will follow and that we
can build a true Corporation also of
Ukrainian and EU Architects to bring
real change on the ground
foreign
[Music]
of work into opportunities
to build a beautiful and Healthy Future
for Ukraine
[Music]